hallo leute
neulich haben wir eine e-mail von roman
erhalten und er hatte eine tolle idee er
fragte uns ob wir ein video aufnehmen
könnten indem wir werben vorstellen die
geräusche oder laute beschreiben wir
fanden diese idee toll und es hat uns
überrascht wie viele solcher werben es
gibt man nennt dieses die wort bildende
lautmalerei man malt also einen laut
oder besser man bildet ein wort das
einen laut nachahmt deshalb wird es auch
klang oder laut nachahmung genannt das
ausgesprochene verb soll sich also
möglichst ähnlich zum gehörten klang
anhören knirschen
knistern klären diese werben sagen euch
nichts keine sorge das sind keine werben
die als anfänger wissen lässt aber sie
werden euch helfen wenn ihr zb gerne
geschichten oder bücher liest wir zeigen
euch heute einige dieser werben los
geht's
knirschen mit
knirscht mit den zähnen
die tür knallt
quietschen die tür
[Musik]
[Applaus]
klappern die tür klappert
knallen mit knall doch die tür nicht so
knattern
das motorrad knattert
prozent die möhren rutschen in der
pfanne
rascheln mit
raschelt mit dem schokoladen papier
schluchzen es gibt keine schokolade mehr
mit schlucht
plätschert
das wasser plätschert
16 asse krächzt wie ein papagei
knacken
möchte eine pizza bestellen hallo aber
es kann sie nur in der leitung hanno
klirren die gläser klirren
scheppern
das geschirr sap hat in der umzugskiste
[Musik]
rippen
die mikrowelle pietsch
ist glücklich mit dem essen
rauschen
das radio raus
[Applaus]
kreischen
mit
greifen der wasserkocher
in dieser episode geht es um werben ich
möchte euch diesbezüglich gerne die app
sieht länger ans herz legen an dieser
app haben wir selbst mitgearbeitet und
ihr seht in den videos öfter mal kari
und janisch oder auch manchmal mich
sieht lang bietet unter anderem einen
kommunikationstrainer mit dem ihr euch
ausschließlich auf die kommunikation
deutscher werben konzentrieren könnt im
kommunikationstrainer könnt ihr
beispielsweise ein level oder eine
bestimmte zeit auswählen und dann die
kommunikation der verben trainieren wir
freuen uns wenn ihr das mal ausprobiert
heule
der sturm heute
posen und brausen das meer toast und
brauchst
krachen die wellen krachen tosend gegen
die wand
doch
es gibt auch ein gewitter es donnert
summen die bienen
[Musik]
zwitschern der vogel zwitschert
schreien die möwe schreibt
nicht zu verwechseln mit dem schreien
von menschen
[Applaus]
winseln hunde winseln wenn sie traurig
oder ängstlich sind
lola ist aber gar nicht traurig
knurren wenn hunde sich bedroht fühlen
knurren sie
aber auch das macht nola nicht wirklich
ticken die uhr tickt
das streichholz
knistern die flamme der kerze knistert
das war unsere episode zu werben die
laute beschreiben wir hoffen euch dröhnt
jetzt nicht der kopf und das ihr viele
neue werben gelernt habt bis bald
[Musik]